Speaker 1: Please welcome
Swyx, Sarah Guo, Elad Gil,
and Chairman and Chief
Executive Officer
of Microsoft, Satya Nadella.
[APPLAUSE]
Satya Nadella:
Hello, Sarah.
Sarah Guo:
Hello.
I'm so excited to be here.
Welcome to a crossover
episode of "No Priors"
and "Latent Space"
with Satya Nadella.
Congratulations on
an amazing Build.
Satya Nadella: Thank
you so much, and it's great
to be with both of you.
I listen to both of the
podcasts all the time.
It's great to be on it.
Elad Gil:
Thank you so much.
Sarah Guo:
You were just talking
about these amazing
announcements
from across the Microsoft
estate all morning for,
I think, three hours.
What is the most important
reflection or takeaway you have?
Satya Nadella:
I'd say, there are --
perhaps, the biggest one
for me is, let's sort
of conceptualize this more as
an ecosystem play, as opposed
to a single model, or even
a single platform, right?
I mean, at least for me,
having grown up at Microsoft,
having seen, whatever, four
major platform shifts,
I sort of fall into that camp
where a platform is defined by,
fundamentally, its ability
to create more value
above the platform, versus
what's captured in the platform.
If you view what's
happening right now,
I think this morning's keynote
was, how can any company,
whether it's an
AI-native company
or a traditional
enterprise company,
participate as a first-class
participant, where
they can point
to AI they create, right?
It's not that they don't
use other people's AI.
Of course they will, but
to me, what's the path?
What's the recipe?
How do I do it?
What does the stack look like?
What does the tooling look like?
What is valuable?
How do you do that?
That's it.
That's sort of our job to do.
Sarah Guo: Ecosystem
strategy is very complicated,
because you end up building
certain components,
partnering for certain
components, and supporting them.
You just announced this
big suite of models.
Tell us a little bit about the
training strategy for Microsoft.
Satya Nadella: Yeah, so the
thing that we wanted to do
with the MAI models
was to build,
and as Mustafa talked
about, first of all,
a great lineage starting
with pre-training,
with very good data quality,
doing all the ablations,
making sure, because in some
sense, it's becoming even harder
to build a clean lineage
model, just because there's
so much stuff out there that
you truly need to ablate
out to be able to have a
fantastic pre-trained model.
In fact, that's one of
the challenges of a lot
of the open-weight models is,
they look great on one benchmark
or two, but they're
not great on practice.
That's why, in fact, even
our FDEs are pretty --
I've gotten really excited
about these MAI models,
because how the heck can a
small 5B model hill climb?
It goes back a little bit to
what I think is, ultimately,
the key thing to
do, which is try
to pursue finding
that cognitive core.
To me, starting with a clean
lineage, then creating
that ability for companies
to be able to use this,
not just as a generalist, but
to create their own specialist
by building this hill-
climbing scaffold around it.
It's not just the model, but if
you have a hill-climb scaffold
around it, then you will
start building your RLE.
You will start
collecting the traces.
Most importantly, you'll
have private evals,
because we know all the evals
out there are good, interesting,
but they're not really that
critical at this point
because they all can be maxed.
The point is, each company will
have its own private eval.
That end-to-end platform story
around our models is, sort
of, what I think is interesting.
Then the one other thing, Sarah,
since you brought that up,
is, I do feel there's
a new frontier.
People talk about
"the frontier,"
and are you "operating
at the frontier?"
Interestingly enough, if you
add a little temporality to it,
you can use, let's say, in fact,
the Land O'Lakes demo we
showed was pretty cool.
We used whatever,
GPT-5.5, right?
Then you collected
a bunch of traces,
and then you took a 5B reasoning
model and achieved higher.
That is another aspect
of what it means
to operate at the frontier.
Swyx:
Yeah, I think, first of all,
I have to congratulate
you on, basically,
on building a frontier
MAI lab inside
of Microsoft in two years.
I'm wondering, you have
all this AI strategy
that you're rolling out.
I'm wondering, what
do you know now
that you wish you could tell
yourself two or three years ago,
three years for the Jensen
partnership, two years for MAI?
Satya Nadella: Yeah, I
mean, I think the thing
that I reflect quite a bit,
right, which is sort of,
obviously, I got into all
this when I got excited
by the Scaling Laws paper,
and when even the OpenAI
partnership came about.
When those folks said, hey,
we're going to really
throw a lot of compute
at transformers,
and they've helped.
The thing that I always
look back and say, wow,
these things do have capability
that they're climbing up.
I mean, a crude way of saying
it is, "intelligence is log
of compute," kind of works.
Now, what I think we
underestimated, perhaps,
is the real-world complexity
of deploying these
so that they actually
deliver the value
in the real world, right?
The outcomes, as measured
by any benchmark,
are interesting/important, but
the true eval is when people
out there are able to do unique
things that they only can value,
and it's very measurable.
That, I wish, we had sort
of even like had more
in our consciousness
as an industry.
Right now, I think when people
say, "Wow, I don't want
to token max," it's an artifact
of us not having taught
ourselves as an industry
that we are using tokens
to create value every
step of the way.
I think that's kind of what
I wish we had gotten there,
but I'm glad we are here.
Elad Gil: What are some of the
use cases that you've seen
that have created the most
value for your customers?
I know that people
talk a lot about code
and I think it's pretty clear
that that's something that's
having very large scale impact.
Are there other areas
that you find in common
that your customers
are really benefiting?
Satya Nadella: Yeah, I think
to your point, obviously,
coding is now god, but it's
interesting, by the way, Elad,
to even talk about the coding.
Coding has worked so well that
we now have to rebuild the IDE.
I mean, it's kind of nuts to
see what we launched, and it's,
like, oh, my God, I have
these hundred-agent sessions.
The cognitive load that
transfers back to me
as a human is so excessive
that now I need a new UI.
Oh, by the way, the chat
as the only artifact
was also impossible.
That's why we need a canvas.
It's kind of interesting
for all the things
about where is software
needed or where is UI needed?
You kind of need that, even for
code, in a fully agentic world.
That said, one of the things
that we are starting to see --
we started seeing it with
CoWork, but even some
of the work we showed with
Autopilot, on what you see
with Claude, is a good one,
because if you sort of think
about it, a lot of human capital
is doing the glue work, right?
If you now can augment
that with tokens/agents
that are long-running,
durable, then your ability
to scale, even what
is still judgment
and glue work, gets
amplified like coding does.
So you can -- I'm positive
that six months from now,
we'll all be saying, oh,
wow, all through the night,
there was a bunch of stuff
that all these autopilots
that I have working
on my behalf,
with my delegated
authority, so to speak --
I can sort of give it, even, my
identity, did a bunch of work.
Then, of course, I'll
need my ADE to say, well,
what did you do, did I
do this work, and so on?
I think that that's where
compressing of workflows,
completing of tasks,
that's where I think a lot
of the value gets created.
Elad Gil: I think you raised
a really interesting point,
which is, there's the actual
agent doing the code
and then there's a
harness around it.
That's the environment.
That's the context.
That's everything you're
setting up as a developer
around actually a coding agent.
What is the harness
for the enterprise?
Is there an equivalent concept
for broader productivity work,
or how do you think
about that concept --
Satya Nadella:
That's right.
In some sense, you kind
of want the harness
to define the models,
the data, and the tools,
so that you have a loop
across those three.
What we are trying to, first
of all, make sure is each
of our products that we build,
whether it's GitHub Copilot
or the Security Copilot, the
stuff we showed with MDASH,
or even the Discovery for
Science, it doesn't matter.
All of them are multi-model
harnesses with tools access,
so that you can do this
progressive disclosure
of tools, even, so that
they're token efficient.
Then you're feeding it with very
rich context,
because that's sort
of the other hard
lesson we have learned
in the last two years
is, oh, my God.
The amount of work you need to
do to prep the context layer,
such that your plan can execute
in the most efficient way,
is where the magic is.
In our case, we have GitHub
harness, which, essentially,
we're using across
all our products.
It's available in Foundry
and we're open --
you can use your Llama
harness, whatever.
You can use any open harness or
any harness of yours and train
with your tools, and multiple
models, and your context.
That's the pitch, because right
now, a lot of dialogue is, hey,
if I train the
harness, plus tools,
and the model together,
you get evals.
What we are proving out is --
and the best example of that is
what we did with MDASH, right,
because when it launched, it
found bugs, or vulnerabilities,
that were not found by Mythos.
There is existence
proof, I would claim,
that you can have a multi-model
harness that can, in fact,
be more performant
in the real world.
Sarah Guo: So, the premise
behind the training
at the independent frontier
labs is really, you know,
we're going to
have these models,
and we'll have an API business.
We'll support enterprises
and startups,
but a first-party product,
be it productivity, or code,
or search, drives the
majority of revenue.
That's a different value
equation than you're describing,
I think, with the
Microsoft ecosystem.
If that's the case --
tell me if it's the case,
because obviously you
have first-party products
and you have
enablement products --
what is the role of
the developer --
what's going to be hard
and the set of skills
and the value capture the
developer has in that world?
Satya Nadella: Yeah, so I think
that there's always going
to be the case that someone
who is super-successful
as a platform builder can also
have first-party products.
It was true with Windows.
It is true with the SaaS side,
and the Cloud side as well,
with us, and others, and so on.
The thing that is, it
should not be a limiter
to other people achieving
that same success, right?
That, I think, is
the core difference.
The network effects this time
around, around intelligence
and such, because they learn
from data and not really lots
of data, it's just a few
samples that you have to see
to understand what's
novel about something.
That's why the game
becomes how to protect.
That's why I would say every
company, having private evals,
may be the biggest IP.
I think about it.
What's that private eval
that you can then use, even a
frontier model to hill-climb on,
and not leak the traces.
Maybe one of the biggest drivers
of IP -- so, in other words,
another asset test is, you
have an eval that's private.
You're using Model
A. Can you switch it
to Model B and climb up?
If you can, then
you're in control.
If you can't, you're
not in control,
and that's where even the
harness decision becomes
super-important, right?
Therefore, having
an open harness,
letting all the models come in,
having your evals, your context,
your tools help you hill-climb,
I think, are the skills
that an AI-native startup
needs, a SaaS company needs,
or every enterprise needs.
Swyx: Yeah, I think, in a
very real way, you are --
Microsoft, historically, was
an operating systems company
and then became a cloud company.
Maybe the third act is
that you're a harness
or evals company, whatever
the conglomerate of concepts
that you want to put together.
I think enabling every company
to have frontier intelligence,
or I forget the exact term that
you use, is the mission.
Satya Nadella:
That's it.
Swyx: That is the platform
promise, that you build with us,
you will get your
intelligence for your data.
Satya Nadella:
That's it.
To me, that is the -- if
there was one tagline
for this entire developer
conference, it is,
"Can everybody operate
at the frontier
with their frontier
intelligence?"
To me, that is so important,
because otherwise,
I don't know how you
achieve stable equilibrium.
Which is, how do I then go and
say, well, my company is going
to have a terminal value,
because I now know how
to continuously compound on top
of what's a platform
that gets better?
When Windows came out, Adobe
build, Autodesk build,
or even like take what Jensen
said, we built DX and he built,
you know, CUDA on top of it.
I mean, I always say
to Jensen, "God,
I got the short end of that.
I wish we had recognized it."
Nevertheless, that idea that
you can build a platform layer
that someone else
can then extend out
and build their own intelligence
layer, in this case,
I think is everything.
Without it, why have a
developer conference?
I can just come and have
you all just worship
at the altar of one model.
That's not a
developer conference.
Swyx: Backstage, we had a
discussion about what is IP
or what is the
value in a company?
It used to be the length of
human experience at the company.
Now it's this other thing, which
is the evals, the experience
in sort of applying
agents to the company.
I just want you to
flesh it out a bit more
because it's very insightful.
Satya Nadella: Yeah, it's
a great way to frame it.
At the end of the day,
every company is going
to have both the human
capital, that is still going
to be super-valuable, because
humans and their ability
to find the gaps that exist
at all times is going
to be the way we all
will create value.
I'm definitely in the camp
that this is going to be
about expressing new forms of
human agency and ambition,
even as token capital
goes up, right?
Let's say any corporation
has lots of tokens
and a lot of human capital.
The question is, how do
you compound the two?
If you have -- if you take
in Teams, I have a bunch
of agents doing work and a
bunch of humans doing work
and the traces between those,
that is really important context
of how that enterprise
is creating value.
Then, that goes back to train
not a generalist model,
but to train the
company veteran agent.
That is super-valuable again,
which is when a company
says it should, in fact,
go on to the balance sheet.
That's how I think about it.
In fact, maybe human capital
was never possible to put
on a balance sheet, because
you didn't know how
to capture the tacit knowledge.
Whereas now, I think
you can with the agents
that have learned through
time, through all the traces.
That's what, at least,
we think will happen.
Swyx: I think the
SEC is going to have
to have accounting standards
for token expertise.
Sarah Guo: You're talking
about the equilibrium state
and a stable equilibrium
where companies have
this compounding value
and can see terminal
value for themselves.
Another challenge to the
considered equilibrium of, okay,
there are applications and
workflows that are common
to a vertical or horizontal.
This was the generation
of SaaS companies,
and Microsoft has lots of
SaaS properties as well.
Then, there are things
that are very specific
to every enterprise that
they're differentiated against.
I'm sure you have heard much
and participated in much
of the debate about
the end of software,
because all these workflows
are cheap to generate now.
Do you think the
equilibrium looks different
between what agents get
built in enterprises,
versus in their
vendors in the future?
Satya Nadella:
Yeah,
so I think what's happening
there is, we had
a particular way
we captured, I would
say, workflow in apps,
because we built a data model.
We schematized some part
of some business process.
We then built a bunch
of business logic,
and then we put a bunch
of UI on top of it.
That's kind of what
every SaaS company --
Sarah Guo:
And a little configuration.
Swyx:
For, like, 20 years.
Satya Nadella:
Right, and that was it.
Interestingly enough, now you
kind of get to relitigate
that vertical stacking.
I still think, for
example, that data model
that you built underneath every
SaaS application is super-good.
Why reinvent it?
My general ledger better
be a general ledger.
I don't need new
schema creation.
In fact, that entity
relationship is actually a
pretty good, robust thing
that I want to feed.
Sarah Guo:
And you want it to be stable.
Satya Nadella:
That's right.
Sarah Guo:
Yeah.
Satya Nadella: The same thing
with business logic, right?
If you look at -- we have
this product called Power BI.
It is dashboards
galore people created.
The beauty underneath
that dashboard is a very
rich semantic model.
Someone took the pain
to create a dashboard
and do all the measures,
and you want that.
That's business logic.
I want that to be
available to me.
I think the challenge
of the SaaS business model
is, we packaged one way.
We now have to learn how
to unbundle these things,
and rebundle in new ways, and
discover new business models.
I mean, if you look at it,
what's happening today
with Microsoft 365
is a great example.
We have this thing
called Work IQ.
In fact, what we are
realizing is, oh, my God,
if you look at it, in fact,
there's a historical
parallel it.
We sold first Exchange
and SharePoint.
Before Teams, we had a
thing called Lync Server,
and what have you.
We thought, oh, that's all
going to move to the cloud,
but little did we realize
that the number of people
who will use servers in the
cloud is 10x, 100x, right,
because people were
not buying servers.
They were just buying
a subscription.
The same thing is now happening
with M365, because with Work IQ,
we have exposed
what is, perhaps,
the most important database in
a company that never got used
as a database because it is
only captive to our apps.
It was all -- email
operated on it.
Teams operated on it, Word,
Excel, PowerPoint, SharePoint.
Now, this is one of the coolest
things I get to do with Work IQ.
I go to a GitHub repo, and I
say, hey, I attended a bunch
of design meetings last
week related to this repo.
Can you capture all that
and tell me what
changes I should make?
I mean, think about that.
It literally can go look
at all those transcripts,
come back with a plan
to change a code base.
Previously, you could never
have thought of using M365
for something like that.
The value creation opportunity
now in the agent world is,
in fact, 10x more, but it
does require us to have --
for example, there's going
to be usage around M365,
which is going to be perhaps
more than even the end users,
and we have to
even re-architect.
In fact, what I use
to serve an inbox
or a mailbox cannot be
used to serve an agent.
That's sort of what we're doing.
Sarah Guo: I don't believe
in permanent business models
for any of these domains,
but in the near term,
do you have a prediction
between outcomes-based pricing,
token-based pricing,
enterprise bundles?
Satya Nadella:
Yeah, the way I think
about this is,
always we've had --
let's even take the
per-user pricing.
The per-user pricing
is really an artifact
of someone creating a budget
needing certainty.
It's the most important thing.
If somebody wants a budget,
they need a per-user,
and per-user is just a set
of entitlements to usage.
That's kind of what it is.
The way is, the first bundling
will be, take some usage,
bundle it into per-user stacks,
and then sell subscriptions.
Subscriptions, I think,
are going to be there.
Per-user is going to be there.
Then, the next big thing
will be consumption.
People will say, "I
want consumption."
It's also possible that people
will say, "I don't even want
to pay for any of
the subscriptions
or the consumption outcome."
Remember, most
people love outcomes
until they have an outcome,
because once you
have an outcome,
it's like giving away a royalty.
I've talked to customers who
love outcome-based pricing
and I say, "I'm all in,"
until they -- oh, my God.
What are you talking about?
You're sharing in my outcome?
No, no, no.
I want you to go back
to per-user pricing,
and I want to do
consumption pricing.
I think that debate will go on.
All of these business models
have a particular time
and a place, versus
one to rule them all.
If anything, if
you're a SaaS vendor
or you're a platform vendor,
having that flexibility --
and quite frankly, we
faced this with GitHub.
We just recently announced a
per-user pricing on GitHub
because little -- GitHub
Copilot was constructed
at a per-user level before
we understood the intensity
of usage of agents.
It was an interactive
way for a developer
to use code-complete
maybe tasks.
It was not, oh, I
launched 10,000 agents
that are going on all day.
That is what the
adjustment is about.
Now that we really want -- there
will always be a per user,
but they will have to
be a consumption meter.
Elad Gil: How do you
think about the durability
of SaaS more generally?
One thing I've observed is, in a
lot of enterprises internally,
there will be teams that
almost have agent euphoria.
They're so excited
about the explosion
of things they can build
that they're trying
to rebuild a lot
of applications.
They're going to their
SaaS vendors and saying,
"We're not going to work
with you anymore," or,
"We're considering an
internal project."
It seems like in
six to nine months,
maybe some of those people will
come back and say, actually,
we can't rebuild everything.
How do you think
about what's durable
in this world and what isn't?
Satya Nadella:
I think we have to go
through one full budget cycle on
this to really see the emergence
of the equilibrium, because
at the end of the day,
there's marginal cost to
even generating the app.
In fact, there can be --
a simple way to say it is, you
should always acquire something
if the marginal cost of building
and maintaining something
on your own is higher.
That should be -- it's
a quantifiable thing.
The maintenance
part is important.
You've got to remember,
hey, all the security stuff
that now AI will find, you
better fix them, too, fast.
Of course, there's a coding
agent to help you with it,
but then that burns tokens, so
whose responsibility is it?
It's kind of like a cycle that
you've got to think through.
I think we have gone
through the excitement
that I can generate
a lot of software.
I think the next thing would be,
what software do I really want
to generate?
What software do I want
to use from others?
How do I compose these two
into some agentic workflow
that I have agency over?
I think there'll be very
little tolerance for anybody
who is inflexible at the vendor
level, but at the same time,
I think that anyone who has
got that flexibility shows up,
delivers the value,
will be back again.
We're selling software, but with
just different business models,
in fact.
Swyx: Speaking
about building software,
one of my favorite moments from,
I think, a previous Build,
maybe one or two years ago,
was they had a section
of you building
your own software.
I'm curious if you're
building anything now.
Satya Nadella:
Yeah, so I think, first of all,
let's face it, building
software has made it possible
for even the incompetence of
a CEO of a company like ours,
you can build, so thank God.
That said, I do feel that
something like GitHub Copilot
to me, and especially the new
sessions app, or the new app,
has just made it so much more
possible for you to have agency
over artifacts that you felt
you couldn't touch before.
For me, as a CEO, even to go to
a code base, to be able to learn
about it -- I remember joining
Microsoft long back, first.
Then, you said, man, everybody
had to go in and look at,
you know, whether it's Cutler's,
Malik, or what have you,
to learn how to
do good C++ code.
So now, that ability to be
more full stack up and down is
so good, but that
doesn't mean every one
of us should be doing
the same thing.
The question is, how do
you then have the ability
to inspect things, learn
things, see things?
I think it's just so much more.
To me, what I'm building a lot
of is these long-running
Foundry agents.
There's Autopilots.
The easiest thing is, to me -- I
think I just built one last week
where the idea was, hey,
can I have an agent
that is continuously monitoring?
Essentially, it's my own
Chief of Staff Autopilot.
We're going to have that,
obviously, in Scout.
That's what we showed, but it is
so easy and trivial to build.
I took Work IQ.
I said, "Take Work IQ.
Go and build a Foundry
long-running agent.
Store all the memory
using Rayfin," basically
at my back end as a service.
Lo and behold, it built it, and
not only built it, I could say,
"Publish to Teams,"
and it published the
damn thing to Teams.
The ability to have
some end-to-end project
like this complete is
just pretty miraculous.
Elad Gil: How do you think that
impacts the different types
of engineering roles that
exist in the future?
Right now, I think there's
a dozen different types
of engineers that you can be
from QA, front end, et cetera.
There's a big swath.
I've heard some people argue
that in four or five years,
we'll basically end up with
four engineering roles.
It'll be people who
are managing agents.
It'll be forward-deployed
engineers, or FDEs.
It'll be security engineers,
and then people working
on large-scale infrastructure
for a small number of services.
Then everything
else just collapses
into the agentic world.
Do you think that's a
correct view of the world?
Satya Nadella:
Yeah, I think we'll have
to experiment our
way through it.
What you said is what -- there
are some very at-scale things.
At LinkedIn, they did
structurally change
and basically built up
a new discipline called
"full-stack builder."
They went and said, hey, let's
bring people from design
and product management,
front-end engineering all --
put them together, but
also have an edge.
It's not like the design person
still doesn't have the design
edge, or the front-end person
doesn't have the front-end edge,
but you can give yourself
a bigger scope in roles
so that you're not
confined to one role.
Then, equally, infrastructure
has become very critical.
In other words, I mean, RLEs,
one thing we've realized is even
for the Excel team, for
example, building the RLE,
in which a reward can be
learned, is actually one
of the hardest
infrastructure problems.
You kind of need
even new talent,
distributed systems people,
even in what was considered
an end-user app team,
because it's a
different skill set.
So, yes, Infrastructure Science
is the other one, obviously.
I think we'll see
how these evolve.
I mean, always, the world will
have a bunch of specialists.
I think the generalist role is
going to be the most exciting,
because the leverage of a
generalist is where we are going
to see the maximum returns.
When you said,
"Hey, are you coding?"
I'm now a generalist.
I basically translated
knowledge work,
which I did, where I created a
Word document, or a spreadsheet,
and now I can build an app.
It's in the same sentence,
that idea that, oh, wow,
my generalist skills have gotten
higher-leverage, I think,
is what we're going to
see across the board.
Sarah Guo: Music to the
ears of CEOs and VCs
that are a little
dangerous and a lot of --
Swyx: It's a golden
age for idea people.
Sarah Guo: Idea people,
yeah, with a lot of agency.
If you take that idea
of personal agency
and you just zoom it out to
the organizational context,
my partner, Mike Vernal, who
actually started his career
at Microsoft, just wrote
an essay where one
of the big takeaways
is, it's an age
where you can be much more
ambitious, and you need
to be, given the pace of the
environment and how quickly,
actually, users and
companies are open
to adopting new technologies.
How do you think about --
I feel silly asking this
of somebody running a
trillion-dollar-plus company
already, but how do you think
about how Microsoft can
be more ambitious now?
Satya Nadella:
It's a great question.
I think the thing in these
types of transitions is
to have a conceptual model
of how work can change to go
after outcomes that you could
hardly imagine previously.
In fact, Kevin Scott
has this nice line,
which is, when you can
make the impossible --
when you're making hard things
easier, that's sort of one point
of leverage, but
true ambition is
about making the
impossible possible.
Now, the thing that is
missing a little bit in all
of our organizations is, what is
that new conceptual model
of what can we build?
What was impossible
and what can we build?
I'll give you one
example of this,
which is, I take great
inspiration from the people
who are managing
the Azure network.
This is from last year.
We were scaling.
You saw that I talked
about how we built
in the last 15 months more
Azure capacity than we built
in the first 15 years.
I mean, it's crazy.
Sarah Guo:
Wild, yeah.
Satya Nadella:
It's pretty wild.
It's the same team.
They saw that and they said,
"This just ain't going to work
if we don't
reconceptualize our work."
They built -- essentially,
they said, our job is not
to do Azure networking.
Our job is to build
the agentic system
that does Azure networking.
These are the folks managing
the 500-plus fiber operators,
managing the van all over.
Fiber operations, ultimately,
is a physical operation.
Things get caught.
Things have to be repaired.
We have fancy words
called DevOps, and so on.
Basically, emails are coming in,
and you've got to go respond
to them, take care of it.
They've built this
agentic system.
They even have a
character for it.
It's called Miles, and it
sort of does all this stuff.
They started sort of screaming
for more tokens, and so on.
They were saying, look, we
don't need a headcount.
We need tokens in order to be
able to manage our operation.
That reconceptualization
of what their work is --
they basically took their
work and made it meta.
That meta work is
now their new work.
In the '80s, if somebody
had come to us and said,
4 billion people are going
to get up in the morning
and start typing, my model would
have been, we need four billion
typists? But we're
not doing typing,
we're doing knowledge work.
That, to me, I think is it.
Whether it's Microsoft, or
whether it's any organization,
is to give ourselves
permission to do new types
of metacognition, meta
work, using these new tools
to change the
outputs that matter
and then, really make the
impossible possible.
Completing that dot, or the
connective tissue across those,
I think, is where a lot
of the enterprise value
will get created.
Swyx: Can we talk
about data centers?
Elad Gil:
Yeah, please ask.
Swyx:
Oh, okay.
Well, this leads nicely
into the data center part.
I'm just impressed with the
sheer scale of the buildout
from Microsoft, but
also everyone else,
that this is redefining what
it means to be a hyperscaler.
I just feel like that is an
unprecedented scale on finances,
on the way you run the
company, but also,
the communities
that are impacted.
Just talk a bit more about what
you're seeing on the ground,
like when you visit your --
Satya Nadella: Yeah, I think
there are two aspects of it.
Obviously, the buildout
is extraordinary.
Nothing like this has happened,
and it's great to be one
of the participants in it, but
you brought up the other part.
I think at this point,
it's clear that unless we,
as an industry, are very
principled about ensuring
that the benefits of all
the stuff we're talking
about are felt in real ways
at the community level --
because this is not
just a campaign.
It has to be real, where
people are saying, look,
this is not changing the
prices on energy for me.
In fact, if anything, it's
bringing down prices because,
long-term, there's going
to be a better grid.
There is going to
be more energy.
Water consumption is,
in fact, not sort of --
in fact, water is
being replenished.
You've got to really educate
folks on truly what's happening,
the closed-loop systems
we are building.
We have to invest
in the training,
the jobs, the tax base.
In fact, the least-talked about
stuff is the amount of jobs
that get created
during construction,
after construction, what's
the tax base that's there
in the community?
All this has to be real.
If that is the case, then
we will have permission.
If it is not, we won't
have permission.
It's as simple as that.
Which is we -- I think
we have to take it
as an industry pretty seriously.
I think it's good for
communities to be skeptical,
ask the hard questions, for us
to do the hard work, earn that,
but at the end of the day,
if we can really be --
I've always felt in human
history, if you use a lot
of energy, but also create
a lot of value for society,
the story has been fantastic.
If you don't do that,
it's not been that great.
This time around, I'm a firm
believer that, ultimately,
if you do have a token economy
that drives productivity,
that drives economic growth,
that drives widespread
participation,
better health outcomes,
then, I think we will
be in a great place.
That's at least what we
all have to be focused on.
Swyx: Yeah, it makes
me think, actually,
that with all these
initiatives that you're doing,
it might be easier to see ROI
in the communities first
before an enterprise.
Satya Nadella: Yeah, I
mean, I think both sides.
In fact, it comes back together.
It has to be, the people in
the communities are going
to be employed, are going
to be participants
in the real economy.
That's, I think, the question.
If the broad economy
is doing well
and the communities are doing
well, the dots get connected.
The market forces are such
that we will connect the dots.
That, I think, is it.
You ought to be able
to see the evidence.
It can't be about
any one company,
but it has to be
broad economic growth
and broad community permission.
Elad Gil: What have you most
updated in your personal models
on -- regarding the
societal impact of AI?
Satya Nadella: So you're
saying what's the --
Elad Gil: What have
you updated most on,
in terms of societal
impact of AI?
Satya Nadella: Yeah, I think
the most critical thing is the
first question we even started
with, which is, we need
to tell the story
and make it real
that everybody has a
real shot to participate
as a first-class participant
in this new economy.
That's kind of, I think, in
the next 12 months, 18 months,
we need a way for people
to say, oh, wow, I get it.
There's going to be tremendous
capability, a tremendous amount
of infrastructure, but I can
see what is going to happen.
Whether it's the benefits, like
health outcomes, or my ability
to create a startup,
or my ability
to run my local store
more efficiently,
it's just happening, and I
see that benefit myself.
That, to me, you know,
earning that permission
in a path-dependent
way, we can't wait.
The one thing I've learned is,
I think the world is going
to be very skeptical of tech
and tech companies
that say, "Trust us.
We've got it.
The future is going
to be glorious."
You kind of have to
deliver tangible benefits,
and quite frankly,
politicians winning elections
because they have advocated
for that, that will be
at least my adjustment.
Without it, thinking
that somehow --
because it's too important
this time around.
It's too much of the economy
for it not to be the case.
Sarah Guo: One very
simple framework I have
for what is going to
be the broad benefit
of AI, beyond the
communities just working
in technology, are sort
of wealth creation.
It's going to happen in a
ton of different companies,
startups and large companies.
Then you have healthcare.
You had amazing demos today.
There are companies
like OpenEvidence.
I think that is happening.
Education seems like another
one that's an obvious good,
where we haven't seen as
much impact as I'd expect.
Do you have a hypothesis on why
that might be, or if it'll come?
Satya Nadella: Yeah, I mean,
I think this is where, again,
how we think about
education, how --
recently, I met with the
founders of Alpha School
and learned a lot about
what they were going about,
and it's fascinating
to listen to how
to even rethink, what does
education really look like,
because I think it's
actually very important.
I'm not saying anything
traditionally being done is
less important.
I was even looking at the
-- it's fascinating to see.
I forget the which
Stanford class
it was, the Agent Guidelines
for CS something, because you
still need people to learn.
I think it's interesting,
in an AI class,
that people were learning how to
apply softmax more appropriately
versus saying, "Hey,
fix my training run."
I think learning
concepts is important.
It's going to be critical,
but the way we create
the incentives,
what are the credentials, how
we value those credentials,
what is the employment
opportunity
for those credentials. I think
that there is a complete change
that has to happen, given the
way to get to information,
the way to educate yourself,
the way to continue
to keep yourself updated
has changed so much.
I think, interestingly enough,
maybe the next big startup
and success story
could be someone
who builds a new university,
or a new pedagogy, of how
to get someone to go
through a curriculum
and find economic opportunity.
That's highly valuable.
Sarah Guo:
Well, that has felt, perhaps,
impossible for a long time, but
it's a great note to end on,
something that
might be possible.
Thank you, Satya.
Satya Nadella:
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Thank you all.
[MUSIC]